[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
رساله جويه من النيتو الى موسكو مناورات
ديفاندر 23 استعراض لقوه والهجوم المضاد
انتصار صغير
بفاتوره باهظه
من الرشا الى الوثائق السريه يصل ميامي
تمهيدا لمحاكمته غدا وانصاره يحشدون
اسعار تذاكر السفر ستبقى مرتفعه على المدى
الطويل لماذا الاجابه في اخبار الساعه
ايطاليا تودع فارس سياستها ورئيس وزرائها
الاسبق سيلفي وبرلسكوني اكثر رجال ايطاليا
نقودا وثراء
[موسيقى]
اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه الحرب
العسكريه في اوكرانيا توازيها حروب اخرى
تاخذ اشكال مختلفه بين روسيا والمعسكر
الغربي فاستعرضوا القوه العسكريه تحول في
حد ذاته الى صراع يطمح كل طرف الى اثبات
تفوقه فيه حلف الناتو الحليف الاول في
حربها ضد موسكو اطلق اضخم مناورات جويه في
تاريخه والتي تحمل اسم 23 مناورات
تستضيفها المانيا وتستمر حتى الثالث
والعشرين من شهر يونيو الجاري
النيتو مناورات جويه اكبر مناورات جويه في
تاريخ حلف شمال الاطلسي تستغرق 12 يوما
تشارك فيها 25 دوله بقياده المانيا مئات
طائره عسكريه ونحو عشره الاف جندي من دول
الناتو القوات الجويه الامريكيه ستشارك
بمئه طائره
2600 جندي
التدريبات تجريف المانيا وتشيك واستونيا
ستشمل تدريبات للنشر الشامل للقوات
والمعدات من الولايات المتحده الى اوروبا
ستعزز هذه التدريبات توافقيه التشغيل
والحمايه من الطائرات بدون طيار ستعمل
القوات الجويه المشتركه على تنفيذ تدريبات
لسد الثغره الامنيه الاوروبيه
قائد القوات الجويه الالمانيه الجنرال
انغو جرهرت قال ان مناوره ايردفندر 23 خطط
لتنفيذها منذ فتره طويله واضاف انها تهدف
لاظهار القدره الدفاعيه لهذا التحالف
وانطلقت في المانيا تدريبات انتشار جوي
وصفت بانها الاكبر في تاريخ حلف شمال
الاطلس من
خلال المناوره نظهر ونثبت ونستعرض القدره
الدفاعيه لهذا التحالف التدريب اشاره لنا
في المقام الاول اعضاء النيتو هم من
يشاركون في هذا التمرين الذي تقوده
المانيا ونظهر اننا قادرون على الدفاع عن
هذا البلد وهذا التحالف
من فريق سمعنا مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنسا
حسين قنيبر حسين اهلا بك بالاضافه اذا الى
هذه المناورات في حلف شمال الاطلسي مؤتمر
صحفي كذلك كان هذا المساء بين الرئيسين
الفرنسي
والمستشار الالماني اهم مواقف الزعماء
الثلاثه
مساء الخير الصهيب هذا اللقاء الثلاثي
انعقد تحت لواء ما يسمى مثلث زيمار وهو
صيغه نشات للتعاون بين كل من هولندا
والمانيا وفرنسا منذ العام واحد وتسعين
قبل ان تتحول هذه الصيغه الى صيغه تشاوريه
قبل كل محادثات اوروبيه مهمه ياتي هذا
اللقاء الثلاثي تمهيدا لقمه النيتو في
فيلينيوس بيليتوانيا في الثاني عشر
والثالث عشر من الشهر المقبل وايضا تمهيدا
للقمه الاوروبيه نهايه الشهر الحالي ابرز
ما قيل في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك في
الاليزيه صدر عن الرئيس الفرنسي الذي قال
ان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد قد بدا بالفعل
وهو سيتواصل على مدى اسابيع وربما على مدى
اشهر من الاكيد ان اوكرانيا لن تصبح محتله
بمعنى ان روسيا لن تتمكن من احتلالها
واوضح
ما الذي استجد من خلال كلام الرئيس ماكرون
في هذا التمايز الفرنسي عن الموقف الغربي
التمايز الفرنسي قائم منذ اللحظه التي
اندلعت فيها الحرب وفي اوكرانيا وقد برز
ذلك من خلال اتصالات هاتفيه منتظمه بين
الرئيسين الروسي والفرنسي استمرت من شباط
فبراير من العام 2022 وتوقفت في ايلول
سبتمبر من العام نفسه وما زال مكروه ضمنا
يطمح في استئناف هذا الحوار مع بوتين
التمايز الفرنسي الليله في المؤتمر الصحفي
التمثل من خلال تاكيد الرئيس ان السلاح
المرسل لاوكرانيا يجب ان يبقى هدفه دفاعيا
ولا يجب ان يستخدم هذا السلاح ابدا
لمهاجمه روسيا هذه اول نقطه يتميز فيها
الرئيس الفرنسي عن شركائه الاوروبيين
والنقطه الثانيه تتعلق بضروره اخضاع
الجنود والضباط الاوكرانيين لدورات تدريب
وتاهيل وتكوين قبل ارسال المزيد من
الاسلحه المتطوره اليهم هذان الموقفان
يركز عليهما الرئيس الفرنسي بشكل
منتظم صهيب حسين قنيبر مباشره من باريس
علموا اوكرانيا يعود لرفرف من جديد في
بلدات كانت خاضعه للسيطره الروسيه فكيان
بدات ربما في جوني اولى ثمار الهجوم
المضاد الذي طال انتظاره في جديد الهجوم
المضاد قالت اوكرانيا ان جنودها استعاد
السيطره على قريه رابعه في جنوب شرقي
البلاد واظهرت لقطات نشرت على الانترنت
جنودا وهم يرفعون العلم الاوكراني في قريه
استروزيف في منطقه دنيا
هجومها المضاده الذي اعلن عن انطلاقته من
قبل الرئيس الاوكراني قبل ايام وكان الجيش
الاوكراني قد نجح في استعاده السيطره على
ثلاث قرى تقع على حافه منطقه دونيسك في
الجنوب الشرقي للبلاد اما شرقا فلم يحقق
الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني اي تقدم كبير حتى
الان رغم زحفه الطفيف في باخمت حسب تاكيد
شرباتي المتحدث باسم القياده العسكريه
الشرقيه للجيش الاوكراني ان القوات
الاوكرانيه واصلت الهجوم المضاد على اطراف
باخموت ودفعت القوات الروسيه للتراجع
لمسافه تصل الى 700 متر
على الطرف الاخر نفت موسكو نجاح الهجوم
المضاده الروسي في تحقيق اي تقدم على ارض
الميدان قالت روسيا ان الهجوم المضاد فشله
حتى الان ونشرت صورا لمركبات ودبابات
قتاليه الامريكيه والمانيه وهي مدمره
وقامت روسيا ببناء تحصيلات دفاعيه متراميه
الاطراف للتصدي لهجوم القوات الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
وصل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامبيلا
تمهيدا لمثوله لاول مره امام محكمه
فيدراليه في ميامي على خلفيه قضيه وجهت له
فيها سبع وثلاثون تهمه من بينها الاحتفاظ
غير القانوني بمعلومات تتعلق بالامن
القومي وعرقله العداله وشهاده الزور
وكانت ترامب قال عبر منصته تروسول انه
يامل ان يشاهد الشعب الامريكي باكمله ما
يفعله اقصى اليسار بالبلاد ووصف ترامبا
الولايات المتحده بانها في حاله تدهور
خطير ومستمر ودعا انصاره للاحتجاج امام
محكمه ميامي بولايه فلوريدا وذلك رفضا
لتوجيه الاتهامات بحق ترامب الساعي للعوده
الى البيت الابيض حيث اعتبر انصاره انها
تستند الى دوافع
معناها من واشنطن مديره مكتب العربيه في
واشنطن ناديه بالبي سي ناديه اهلا بك معنا
سابقا مثول ترامب امام القاضي في نيويورك
في قضيه
وصفها بعض القانونيين بانها يعني قضيه
تافهه نسبيا بالنظر الى مثوله الان غدا
امام القاضي في محكمه ميامي ما مدى خطوره
موقف ترامب
اولا هناك اختلاف كبير بين نيويورك وبين
فلوريدا محكمه فلوريدا هي محكمه فيدراليه
ايضا التهم الموجهه ضد ترامب هي تهم تتعلق
بالامن الوطني الامريكي وبالتالي نتحدث عن
وثائق سريه نتحدث عن برنامج ايران النووي
نتحدث عن قدرات الولايات المتحده الدفاعيه
وهناك هيئه محلفين هناك ادله ضده وخصوصا
التسجيل الصوتي الذي يقال بان ترامب كان
يقول فيه بان الجيران الميلي اتهموه بانه
يريد توجيه ضربه عسكريه لايران والعكس هو
الصحيح ان ميلي هو الذي لديه هذه الخطط
وقال لشخص معه عندما كان يلعب الجولف في
بعض من بعد
نيجرزي بانه لا يستطيع ان نزع السريه عن
هذه الوثائق لانه ترك البيت الابيض وهذا
عكس ما قاله الرئيس ترامب منذ البدايه
بانه لدي هذه الصلاحيه بنجع السريه على
هذه الوثائق وبال لا داعي الاقتحام منزله
ومنتجعه في مرالو وان القوات الفيدراليه
لم تكن طبعا
تنفذ القانون بل انها استقصدته انه ضحيه
من ما يسميه الدوله العميقه طيب وبالنظر
الى هذا الاستهداف كذلك هناك تجييش لانصار
دونالد ترامب غدا ما الذي تتحسب له
السلطات الامريكيه هل هو فقط ضغط بالراي
العام او على الراي العام ام فقط ام فعلا
هناك مخاطر لانزلاق الوضع الامني
في
الواقع الكثير من
الاجراءات تخوف ليس فقط من دعوه الرئيس
اللي انصاره بالتجمع وطبعا هذا التجمع كما
قال الرئيس ترامب يجب ان يكون سلمى لكن
هناك تخوف من العناصر التي تنتمي لجماعات
عرقيه متطرفه مثل حراس القسم ومثل براج
بويز وغيرهم الذين كان لهم دور في ربما
نقل هذه الاحتجاجات من السلميه الى العنف
كما رايناه في احداث الكابيتال لذا الشرطه
لن تترك اي مجال للتظاهر واذا كان هناك
تظاهر يمكن ان يتحول الى تظاهر عنيف فسيتم
اعتقال كل شخص سواء كان امام المحكمه او
بالقرب من منزل ترامب في ولايه فلوريدا
محاموت رانك مشاهدينا يجذفون عكس التيار
فبدل ان يدافع عن موكلهم فانهم يورطونه من
خلال شهاداتهم حيث جديد تكشف في قضيه
احتفاظ ترامب بالوثائق السريه ويتعلق
بالاساس بفريقه القانوني فمحاموت ترامب
الذين كانوا من المفترض ان يدافعوا عن
موكلهم لعبوا دورا عكسيا من خلال المساهمه
في ادانته فنقلا عن صحيفه فان لائحه
الاتهامات المواجهه ضد ترامب استندت على
شهادات احد محاميه
الحديث هنا عن محامي ترامب ايضا كوكورن
والذي ادنى بشهادته التي منحت المدعين
العامين دوافع لملاحقه حسب لائحه الاتهام
فقد ضغطت ترامب على محاميه كوكرا لمنع
المحققين من استعاده روزا من الوثائق
السريه بل ان ترامب اقترح على محاميه ان
يكذب امام المحققين ويحجب الوثائق تماما
الكلام منقول هنا عن محاميه نفسه وفي
واحده من اكثر المقاطع ادانه وصف كوكرا
فكيف اقترح عليه ترامب انتزاع الوثائق
الخطيره وعدم تسليمها الى المدعين
الفيدرالي
محامي ترامب بشهادته كان يتطلب استثناء
قانونيا على اعتبار ان القاعده القانونيه
تحفظ للمحامي حق الالتزام بالصمت حفاظا
على سريه القضيه لكن المستشار الخاص
المشرف على التحقيق
نجح في الحصول على الاستثناء القانوني وهو
ما لم يرق كثيرا بالطبع وهي ليست المره
الاولى التي يكون فيها محامو ترامب سببا
في تورطه امام القضاء فقد سبق لمحاميه
السابق مايكل كوهين ان ادلى بشهادات ورطت
في قضيه دفع اموال لشراء صمت الممثله
الاباحيه
يمثل امام المحكمه الاتحاديه بميامي وسيتم
الاستماع لترامب بخصوص تهم المواجهه اليه
وذلك بهدف النظر في امكانيه احالته
للمحاكمه ام لا المحتمل ان يتم حجز ترامب
قبل مثوله امام القاضي لكن من المستبعد ان
تقيد يداه او تنتقط له صور من الممكن
نظريا وضع ترامب في الحبس الاحتياطي اثناء
انتظار المحاكمه لكن من المستبعد جدا ان
يامر القاضي بذلك وفي حاله حاله القضيه
للمحاكمه سيكون من المرجح اعتماد كوكرا
لمحامي ترامب كشاهد رئيسي
صحيح ان نسمه ترامب هو الاكثر ارتباطا
بملف الوثائق السريه لكن لا يجب ان ننسى
ان هناك اسمين اخرين متورطان في قضيه
مشابهه الحديث هنا هو عن الرئيس الحليب جو
بايدن ونائب ترامب السابق وتبدو حاله
ترامب الاسوا فهو يواجه سبعه من تتعلق
بوثائق تم العثور عليها في منزله في
فلوريدا اما بايدن فقد تم العثور على
وثائق مصنفه على انها سريه اثناء نقل
صناديق تخصه من مكتبه في مركز ابحاث
بواشنطن فضلا عن العثور على دفعه اخرى في
مراب منزله بولايه دلاور وفيما يخص نائب
الرئيس السابق مايك بانس
العثور شهر يناير الماضي على وثائق غير
مؤمنه في منزله بولايه انديانا
فما هو الفرق يا ترى بين الحالات الثلاث
ولماذا حاله ترامب هي الاكثر تعقيدا
اسباب التي جعلت الاكثر خطوره هو عدد
الوثائق التي تم العثور عليها عند كل طرف
هؤلاء فبينما تم العثور على عشر وثائق
سريه لدى بايدن و 12 وثيقه سريه وجد
المحققون
325 ملفا سريا لدى ترامب السبب الثاني
الذي زاد من تعقيد وضع اكرم هو رده فعله
غير المتعاونه مع المحققين حيث بادر الى
اتهام مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي بتدبير
هذه القضيه لدوافع سياسيه في المقابل فان
بايدن وان تاخر في الاعلان عن اكتشاف
الوثائق الا انه ابدى استعداده الكامل
للتعاون مع المحققين اما مايك بانس فقد
شدد على ان الوثائق وصلت الى منزله عن غير
قصد مبدئيا استعداده لتحمل المسؤوليه
الكامله عن هذا الخطا على حد قوله
مع الانا من واشنطن طارق الشامل السياسي
استاذ طارق اهلا بكم معنا اذا كما تبعنا
ليست ترامب وحده من اخذ معه وثائق سريه
تشكل خطره على الامن القومي الى البيت
فعلها والرئيس الحالي ايضا جو بايدن فعل
ذلك ايضا فهل هناك قسوه اكثر في التعامل
مع ترامب ام لا
تحياتي لك استاذ صهيب للساده المشاهدين
يعني بالتاكيد بعض الناس يعني يعتقدون ذلك
الجمهوريون يعتقدون ذلك وحلفاء ترامب
بالتاكيد يقولون ان المحاكمه السياسيه
بالاساس وانه يعني ترامب هو بطبيعه شخصيته
هو شخص غير منظم شخصيه متسلطه يعني معروف
عنه هذا السلوك لكن سلوكه ليس اجراميا هذا
هو انصاره وبالتالي هم يرون انه لم يقصد
وليست هناك تهمه موجهه الي بانه تعاون مع
اجنبيه او انه وفر هذه المعلومات لاجهزه
اجنبيه وبالتالي يجب ان يتعاملوا معه بحسن
نيه لكن خصومه
بالتاكيد الجوانب القانونيه هنا في وزاره
العدل يرون انه لم يتعاونوا وانه يعني فوت
عليه الفرصه وهذا بالمنى
له ايضا يعني المرشح الرئاسي السابق قال
انه جلب ترامب جلب على نفسه هذا الاتهام
لانه لم يتعاون في البدايه وانه لم يعطي
الوثائق الى السلطات الفيدراليه الحكوميه
وبالتالي هنا نشهد اختلافا كما تفضلت انت
قبل قليل في كيفيه التعامل مع الوثائق لكن
بالتاكيد هذه النظره تسود لدى الجمهوريين
الذين يرون ايضا انه رئيس السابق بن
كلينتون احتفظ بشرائط مسجله معه في نهايه
التسعينيات او مع في عام 2000 حينما خرج
من السلطه واحتفظ بها وكان هناك يعني
مجموعه قضائيه تسمى
فوق هذه هذه المجموعه طلبت من
المحكمه ان بحكم الحصول على المعلومات
وحريه الق المعلومات ان تحصل على هذه
الوثائق حوزه نعم غير موضوع الوثائق نعم
على ذكر ذلك فعلا هناك ليس فقط هناك من
يقارن الان بين قضيه الوثائق السريه مع
قضيه البريد الالكتروني لهلاري كلينتون
وتهديد للامن القومي هل ترى حقا ان هناك
تشابه في الحيثيات وان كان يعني هناك
اختلافات عمليه في الموضوع
نعم هذه ايضا نقطه مهمه يعني البعض يقول
ان هيلاري كلينتون كانت تفعل نفس الشيء
انها يعني تحايلت بانها لم تقدم كل
الايميلات التي كان من المفترض ان يعني
انها حذفتها في البدايه وقالت
اكتشف الاف بي اي انه هناك ايميلات اخرى
كانت موجوده ايضا ولكن حسب ما قال
في هذا الوقت انه لم تكن هناك
نيه سيئه لدى هلال وبالتالي هو تعامل ايضا
مع فكره النيه هنا وبالتالي هناك الامور
كما من يرى انه كان هناك نوع من يعني عدم
الازدواجيه المعايير بمعنى اخر بين
التعامل مع الديمقراطيين ومع الجمهوريين
وبالتحديد هنا الرئيس
ترامبا الذي هو يعني لا يروق لكثير من
الديمقراطيين ولكثير ايضا من المستقلين
شكرا جزيلا لك طارق الشامي الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي كنت معنا من واشنطن العاصمه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه ايطاليا تودع
فارس سياستها ورئيس وزرائها الاسبق سيلفي
اوبر لسكوني اكثر رجال ايطاليا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى السودان الان الهيئه
الحكوميه للتنميه تدخل على خط البحث عن
سبل لحل الازمه السودانيه المنظمه عقدت
قيمه لها في جيبوتي بمشاركه رؤساء جنوب
السودان كينيا وجيبوتي وذلك بهدف اقناع
طرفي الازمه باجراء حوار ينهي القتال
بينهما وفي عقب قمه جيبوتي حذر رئيس
مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي موسى فكي من ان
استمرار الصراع في السودان يهدد بجر
البلاد الى حرب اهليه واسعه النطاق اضاف
فكي ان الازمه السودانيه تتطلب حلا سريعا
وموحدا من دون تاجيل
الازمه العميقه والعنفه في السودان
والتهديدات الخطيره التي تمثلها لوجود هذه
البلاد والمنطقه كلها واضحه جدا كل
التحليلات تتفق على ان هذه الحرب في حال
لم تتوقف ستفضي لاندلاع حرب اهليه وستعم
الفوضى كما انها ستؤدد انهيار الدوله
بالكامل الاليه الثلاثيه التزمت بتوفير
الدعم للسودان لوقف الحرب وتوفير
المساعدات الانسانيه لكل من يحتاج اليها
كما تلتزم بمساعده السودانيين الى الذهاب
نحو حوار وطني شامل ومخطط يقوده
السودانيون انفسهم بعيدا عن اي تاثيرات
خارجيه
هذا واستمرت الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع في اكثر من جبهه فلليوم
الثاني على التوالي شهدت العاصمه
السودانيه قتالا عنيفا بالمدافع والطيران
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع بعد الهدنه
القصيره وتبادل جيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريعه الاتهامات بشان هجمات حيث قال
الجيش ان الدعم السريع شنا قصفا مدفعيا
وصاروخيا على مناطق سكنيه في جنوب الخرطوم
في المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع الجيش
بالاستمرار في الهجوم عليها في عدد من
المحاور بمدن العاصمه
[موسيقى]
اخبار غير ساره لمحبي السفر ارتفاع اسعار
تذاكر الطائرات الذي هز السوق العالمي
سيبقى مستمرا لفتره طويله ارتفاع قد يبدو
مستغربا في ظل استقرار اسعار الوقود في
الفتره الماضيه فسعر الوقود يمثل ما يقارب
30% من تكاليف الشركات الطيران وعاده ما
يكون له تاثير كبير على اسعار التذاكر
هو سبب استمرار ارتفاع تكاليف تذاكر
الطيران يا ترى في اجابتها على هذا السؤال
تقول توميس كبيره الاقتصاديين في الاتحاد
العالمي للنقل الجوي ان تكاليف اليد
العامله وتكاليف سلسله التوريد اخذت
بالارتفاع جاته يعتبر الخبير في قطاع
الطيران
ان المساله الاساسيه لا تكمن في اسعار
النفط بمقدار ما تكمن في عدم وجود مقاعد
كافيه في الطائرات مع عدد كبير من الركب
تشير التوقعات الى ان العطله الصيفيه هذا
العام ستؤذي جيوب المسافرين فيما تشكل
انفراجات لشركات الطيران بعد الخسائر
الناتجه عن اغلاقات كورونا فيما تبقى
المطارات عالقه بين الزياد عدد المسافرين
وعدم القدره الماليه على مواكبه الطلب
الكبير وبحسب تصريح للرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
راين اير لصحيفه التليجراف مايكل اوليري
فان متوسط اسعار التذاكر في جميع انحاء
اوروبا ارتفع 20% العام الماضي ويتوقع هذا
الصيف ان تقفز الاسعار مره اخرى بالقدر
نفسه تقريبا ووفقا لمدير السفر في امريكا
فان الرحله من نيويورك الى هونغ كونغ في
الدرجه الاقتصاديه تكلف اليوم ضعف ما كانت
عليه في عام 2019 وما يقرب من الثلث اكثر
من العام الماضي والسبب هو ان شركات
الطيران لديها عدد اقل من المقاعد المتاحه
حاليا مقارنه بمست قبل الجائحه بسبب اتجاه
اطلق عليه اسم السفر الانتقامي حيث يخطط
الناس لرحلات اطول في صيف 20 23 هذا
بالتاكيد ترجم الى عوائد جاءت ضعف
التوقعات فقط سجلت شركه اي اي جي المالكه
للخطوط الجويه البريطانيه ارباحا فصليه
افضل من المتوقع ورفع التوقعاتها للعام
باكمله واعلنت طيران الامارات والخطوط
الجويه سنغافوريه عن تحقيق ارباح قياسيه
ايضا وبحسب لايت ضعفت شركات الطيران
العالميه توقعات ارباحها لعام 2023 الى
9.8 مليار دولار من 4.7 مليار دولار اذا
تبدو الصوره ايجابيه لشركات الطيران ولكن
بحسب مجلس المطارات الدولي لمنطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ فان الزياده الحاده في
اسعار تذاكر الطيران تعيق تعافي النظام
البيئي للطيران
وخصوصا المطارات فقد خسر العديد من
المساهمين في المطارات اموالهم لمده عشره
فصول متتاليه اذ لا تزال المطارات تفتقر
الى المرونه لرفع اسعار الرسوم والتعريفات
وحذر مطار لندن هيثرو من الخسائر المستمره
وامتنع عن دفع الارباح للمساهمين
وكانت قد اشتدت الخلافات المتكرره حول
رسوم الهبوط بالمطار في اعقاب كورونا
افتلقت شركات الطيران المزيد من الدعم
المالي المباشر ولديه الان الحريه في رفع
الاسعار بالسرعه في الوقت الذي تواصل فيه
المطارات ضخ الموارد في منشاتها من توسعات
وتمديد المدارج والاتمه وتركيب اجهزه مسح
متطوره دون الحصول على استثمارات اضافيه
قال سامي نائب الرئيس في اي سياف المختصه
بابحاث السفر والضيافه بالنسبه للمطارات
ياتي 60% من ايراداتها من رسوم الهبوط
بينما بالنسبه لشركات الطيران تمثل رسوم
المطر جزءا صغيرا من اجمالي تكاليفها عاده
في حدود خمسه الى سته في المئه
[موسيقى]
معنا من فريسه البحث الاقتصادي الدكتور
ردانيا الملحم دكتور دانيال اهلا بك معنا
هل شركات الطيران تريد تعويض الخسائر التي
منيت بها خلال فتره اغلاقات كورونا ولذلك
اسعار تذاكر الطيران ستستمر في الارتفاع
تحيه لك سيدي والمشاهدين الكرام نعم جزئيا
نستطيع القول لانه عمليا ارتفاع التكاليف
او ارتفاع هوامش الربحيه الذي اضافتها
الشركات الطيران اتى متاخر نوعا ما هي لم
تتدخل بشكل بشكل كبير ولم ترفع الاسعار
بشكل مباشر بعد جائحه كورونا انما اخذت
فتره طويله خشيه من ان المسافرين لقد كانت
كان لدى المسافرين حساسيه على السفر
وبالتالي لم ترفع الاسعار بشكل مباشر انما
رفعتها بشكل متاخر ولكن الارتفاع اليوم لا
يتوقف فقط على الهوامش الربحيه الذي
فرضتها شركه طيران هناك الكثير من العوامل
كما ذكرتم في التقرير هناك الطلب كبير جدا
اضافه الى عرض كل بنسبه ايضا ملحوظه لان
الكثير من الشركات الطيران نتيجه الخسائر
التي كملتها ما بعد الجائحه قطعت الكثير
من الخطوط وعندما نقول قطعه الكثير من
الخطوط الذي كانت تعد خاسره بدا عمليا
المنافسه تنخفض وبالتالي الخطوط الجويه
المتوفره على بعض الاماكن ادى الى ارتفاع
اسعار وهذا بالاضافه الى ارتفاع التضخم
وارتفاع تكاليف التشغيليه الى ذلك كل ادت
هذه العوامل الى رفع الاسعار ومن الممكن
ان تستمر خلال فتره معينه بهذا الارتفاع
نعم لكن دكتور دانيال تعلم جيدا نحن الان
مقبلون على فتره الاجازه الصيفيه
والمغتربون خاصه يعني ينتظرون هذه الفتره
من السنه للسفر الى بلدانهم الاصليه
لتقضيه الاجازه الصيفيه مع عائلاتهم في
بلدهم الاصلي هل من نصائح يمكن ان تسديها
للمشاهدين حتى يتمكنوا من قضاء هذه
الاجازه باسعار يعني مخففه قليلا
اليوم المؤسف جدا اليوم ان الاسعار لم
تنخفض بالشلب على المدى لا على المدى
القصير وعلى المدى الطويل حتى لو انخفض
التضخم عمليا نوعا ما ولكن التضخم الناتج
عن قطاع الخدمات قوي جدا ولا يمكن ان يكون
انه سوف ينخفض خلال الاشهر القليله
المقبله لانه عمليا هناك الكثير من النقص
اليد العامله في هذه القطاعات وخاصه نتكلم
عن الدول العشرين او الدول
باغلب سوى العشرين هناك نص كبير في اليد
العامله وقاصه في طاعه الخدمات وهذا يضغط
عمليا على قطاعات النقل وخاصه النقل الجوي
وقطاع الطيران وبالتالي عندما نرى ان
عمليا اذا تضخم الناتج عن الخدمات لن
يستطيع ان ينخفض خلال الفتره المقبله هذا
يؤدي الى زياده الاجور وزياده بعض
المصاريف اضافه لانك تقول
للراغبين في السفر انه لا نسافر هذا الصيف
هذا هو الحال
لا انا اعتقد ان اسعار الطيران لا يمكن
الانتظار ان الاسعار الطيران سوف تنخفض
الى ما كانت عليه مستويات 2019 هي سوف
تستمر في الارتفاع وفي افضل الحالات سوف
تستقر لان اليوم هناك القوانين الكثير من
القوانين العالميه تفرض وشركه طيران يجب
ان تحترمها وهذا يؤدي وخاصه فيما يتعلق في
الانبعاثات غاز الكربون وهذا بطبيعه الحال
سوف يؤدي الى رفع في اسعار التذاكر اعتقد
في المدى السنتين مقبلتين سوف تستقر
الاسعار ولا استطيع يمكن ان تنخفض الى
مستويات 2019 بتقديري انا شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور دانيال ملحم انت الباحث الاقتصادي
كنت معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
وهناك شركات طيران جديده تفتح الان حيث
كشف طيران الرياض عن تصميم الهويه البصريه
والفئه الاولى من التصميم الخارجي لاسطولي
طائراته على ان يتم اعلان التصميم الثاني
في المستقبل القريب حيث تم اطلاقه حفل
تدشين الهويه بصريه والكشف عن التصميم
الخارجي للطائره في مطار الملك خالد
الدولي بالرياض ليمثل احتفال العاصمه
السعوديه بالناقل الوطني الجديد
[موسيقى]
رئيس الوزراء الايطالي الاسبق سيلفي
وبرلسكوني يرحل تاركا خلفه ارثا سياسيا
ورياضيا كبيرا اذ يعتبر احد اكثر الرجال
نفوذا في تاريخ ايطاليا الحديث نظرا
لتاثيره تاثير سياساته على المجتمع
الايطالي وثقافته بشكل عام لكن الرجل ترك
ايضا ارثا ماليا مهما متمثلا في شركاته
الاعلاميه انباء وفاه الرجل تسببت في
ارتفاع اسهم شركه ميديا التي تساهم فيها
عائلته وارتفعت اسهم شركه بيرلس كوني
الاعلاميه بما يصل الى عشره في المئه بعد
الاعلان عن وفاته
انتعاش اسهم شركه بيلا سكوني يدل على
الخيارات التي قد تنفتح امام الشركه بعد
خروج مؤسسها من المشهد
ويراهن بعض المستثمرين على ان يكون ورثه
اكثر استعدادا للبحث عن شريك لميديا فور
يوروب او للبيع لمنافس اكبر ولم يعلن رجل
الاعمال المتوفى عواريف لكن اشخاصا مطلعين
قالوا ان ابنته الكبرى مارينا هي التي
ستتولى زمام الامور على الارجح
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من روما ينضم الينا الدكتور صبري حسن عضو
حزب اتسيوني الايطاليه دكتور صبري اهلا بك
معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
على مدار حياته اربع حكومات في ايطاليا
وطبعا شكل امبراطوريه اعلاميه ورياضيه
كذلك وامبراطوريه ماليه كبيره
وشكل على مفارقه في المشهد الايطالي بشكل
عام
لماذا برايك يتمكن من حفر اسمه في التاريخ
الايطالي رغم فضائحه المتعدده
في بدايه حياته كان رجل مثابر عملي وانخرط
في اعمال اداريه وماليه وتجاريه وبالذات
في المقاولات وبدا هذا رصيد ويتقسم من
خلال مهاراته الفرديه حتى تمكن بدخوله في
اطار الاعلام بشكل مباشر والتلفزه بشكل
خاص وعلى هذا الاساس كانوا حضوره حضور
ايجابي في المشهد الايطالي حتى تبنى
اشياء جميله جدا في الاطار الرياضي
والاعلامي والثقافي حتى
شعبه الفكره في تكوين حزب في عام
1994 وهذا الحزب دخل في تجربه رائده وحققت
انتصار في الكتله اليمنيه التي كان
يتراسها وعلى هذا الاساس نجاحه تجسد من
خلال الصعود والهبوط
وتكوين عده اشياء ايجابيه دكتور صبري يعني
مزاوجته بين المال والسياسه يعني نجح في
المال وبالتالي نجح في السياسه بعدها في
الاعلام وفي المجال الرياضي كذلك فبالتالي
هذا كل هذا ساهم في يعني بروز اسم بيرلس
كوني بشكل كبير
بالطبع هذه واحده من الاشياء الاساسيه لكن
لاعبه المهاره الذاتيه والخبره
واداره بانه يواكب كل حدث كان تجاري او
رياضي وكل شيء وكان هناك نسبه كبيره من
النجاح وهذا النجاح جسد شخصيه مميزه كان
في ديك الفتره الايطال بحاجه ماسه لوجود
شخص في هذا التكوين في هذا الخصوصيات
واعطى صوت بما معناه انه الجديد القادم في
تحسين اوضاع ايطاليا والمجتمع الايطالي
دكتور صبري يوصف بانه اكثر الشخصيات نفوذا
في ايطاليا حتى وفاته برايك هل سيستمر هذا
النفوذ بالنسبه لحزبه السياسي بالنسبه
لامبراطوريته الاعلاميه كذلك وبالنسبه
لعائلته وورثته كذلك هل سيستمر النفوذ
البرلسكوني
حقيقه هذه اشياء من الجميع يتساءل حول هذا
الموضوع لكن بالطبع هو حقق شيء كبير جدا
في تكوين الكتله
اليمين في اطار السلطه الدستوريه في
ايطاليا والحزب الحاكم حاليا هو ثمره من
ثمرات بيرلس كوني في خلق الكتله اليمينيه
وهذا يظل مكسب كبير جدا وحتى من الذين
يحكمون في اطار الحياه اليوميه السياسيه
يشهدون بهذا المكسب ويكون له كل الاحترام
وتقدير في الجانب السياسي هو احدى مؤسسين
القدره اليمينيه في البرلمان وفي البرلمان
الاوروبي والبرلماني اما يتعلق في الثروه
وافاق المستقبليه بالطبع اولادهم تمرسوا
فتره طويله وعندهم الحدث بانهم يكونوا
موفقين على اعتبار انه
انتهاء حدثه كشخص في هذا اليوم بيعطلهم
فرصه كبيره بانهم يفكروا في العمق وفي في
تكوين هذه الثروه على اساس انها تكون ذات
رياده وذات مستقبل قادم للايطالي وللعائله
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور صبري حسن عضو حزمه
سيونيا الايطاليه كنت معنا من روما
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الملك تشارلز
يمتطي الجواد في اول عرض بمناسبه عيد
ميلاده منذ اعتلائه العرش
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد اغلقت السلطات
الباكستانيه شواطئ مدينه كراش الساحليه
وامرت الصيادين بالعوده الى منازلهم تحسبا
لوصول اعصار بيبارجوي حيث اغلقت جميع
المرافق التجاريه القريبه من الشاطئ لتجنب
وقوع اي خسائر في الارواح كما امرت
السلطات قوارب الصيد بالعوده بسبب التهديد
الذي يمثله الاعصار القادم واشرت السلطات
الباكستانيه في بيانها الاخير الى انها
بدات باجلاء اكثر من 80 الف شخص معرضين
للخطر مؤكده ان الامر امر الاجلاء بات
الزميا وليس خيارا
[موسيقى]
كذا امين امانه الحج والعمره بولايه نهر
النيل عبد الرؤوف حسن ان الولايه قد
استقبلت بالفعل
847 من حجاج ولايه الخرطوم وصلوا الولايه
لاستكمال اجراءات حجهم بعد تعسر الاوضاع
الامنيه في الخرطبه
[موسيقى]
بمجرد ما اول حاجه جانا هنا بجواز من ناس
الخرطوم نحن طوالي استلمنا الجوازات
حقاتهم وبووبناها واشتغلنا معاهم لحد من
الاول لحاج لحتى 847 حجاج الخرطوم الان
الموجودين معنا هنا تم الحمد لله ترتيبه
وترتيب افواجا حتى انه نحن مندوبنا سافر
الى بورسودان حتى انه يتم التاشيره ان شاء
الله خلال اليوم باذن الله حيتم ان شاء
الله اعلان
افواج لهم وترتيبات افواجهم وبنفس
الاجراءات تم عندنا هنا في نهر النيل
بالتطعيم وان شاء الله ولكشفه الطبي تمت
كل الاجراءات على ما يرام ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
اعلن قصر وباكينج امام الملك تشال الثالث
سينتطي صهوه جوادنا السبت للمشاركه للمره
الاولى منذ توليه العرش وذلك في العرض
السنوي للاحتفالي بعيد ميلاده هذا ويحتفل
الملوك البريطانيون باعياد ميلادهم مرتين
في السنه وترجع اصول هذا الاحتفال الذي
يطلق عليه اسم حشد الالوان الى
الاستعدادات للحرب حين كانت تعرض الرايات
المختلفه على الجنود حتى يتمكنوا من
التمييز بينها في حمئه المعارك
اخبار الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز
العناوين
رساله جويه من النيتو الى موسكو مناوره
دفندر 23 استعراضا لقوه النيتو والهجوم
المضاد انتصار صغير بفاتوره باهظه
من الرشا الى الوثائق السريه ترامب يصل
ميامي تمهيدا لمحاكمته غدا وانصاره يحشدون
اسعار تذاكر السفر ستبقى مرتفعه على المدى
الطويل لماذا عرفنا الاجابه في اخبار
الساعه
ايطاليا تودع فارس سياستها ورئيس وزرائها
الاسبق سيلفيو بيرلس كوني اكثر رجال
ايطاليا نفوذا وثران
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
على العربيه على صفحاتنا على مواقع
التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات